vous voyez le silence
certains d'entre vous vont le trouver
agréable
enfin du silence dans ce monde qui fait
tellement de bruit
d'autres en revanche vous le trouvez
gênant
déstabilisant peut-être même
et bien moi je me suis trouvé dans ce
cas là récemment
j'interviens à la maison d'arrêt de
Nanterre en gros en prison
et là voir certains de vos visages je me
dis peut-être qu'il manque quelques
éléments à cet introduction
allez on revient en arrière avril
dernier du coup je vais à la maison
d'arrêt Nanterre je viens discuter
d'entrepreneuriat avec des détenus dans
ce qu'on appelle un groupe de parole
alors pour ceux qui connaissent du
marketing un focus group
c'est quelque chose de en train de
tension
c'est un milieu qu'on connaît pas
et en tout cas que je vous invite à
essayer de pas connaître
c'est aussi spécial de rencontrer des
détenus
c'est toujours différent mais ce jour-là
précisément ça va être encore plus
particulier pour moi
pour contextualiser
j'étais venu en fait avec la Croix-Rouge
française parlait d'entrepreneuriat
pourquoi entrepreneur en fait on voulait
voir si l'entrepreneuriat était connu
des détenus et voir ce qu'ils pensaient
de l'entrepreneuriat
et du coup lors du focus group de ce
groupe de parole je leur ai posé cette
question
est-ce que selon vous l'entrepreneuriat
est une possibilité de réinsertion
alors parmi tous les témoignages qu'on a
pu avoir les peurs les motivations
les réelles envies ou les réels pas du
tout envie ça arrive aussi
bah il y a une prise de parole qui Menta
va m'étonner me choquer en tout cas
c'est pas la prise de parole qui va
mettre non c'est la personne qui va la
faire
mais avant ça faut que je vous explique
un peu ce que c'est la détention
la détention c'est mettre quelqu'un du
coup derrière les barreaux c'est
l'expression qu'on donne et mettre
quelqu'un derrière les barreaux bah
c'est retirer toute forme de liberté à
quelqu'un
retirez toutes sortes de liberté une
personne ça peut faire peur
mais retrouver toutes ces libertés quand
on sort de détention ça fait peur aussi
aux détenus
et là parmi toutes les peurs qu'ils ont
évoqué parmi toutes les motivations bah
il y a une personne qui nous a dit moi
j'ai pas peur de revenir à la liberté
j'ai pas peur de me réinsérer
et tu nous as dit justement à travers
cette question moi mon emploi je sais
très bien que je vais l'avoir
vous allez me dire Quentin qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire cette personne
bah cette personne elle veut s'occuper
des espaces verts
pour réutiliser ces mots il veut
s'occuper de la nature
et lui sa peur c'est pas trop un métier
dedans non
ça peut à lui c'est pas pouvoir faire
son métier dans 5 10 ou 15 ans
sécheresse manque d'eau tempête en deux
mots
réchauffement climatique
cette personne là dans un groupe de
parole en détention au travers d'autres
détenus à témoigner d'un comportement
une peur qu'on est peut-être nombreux à
voir dans cette salle en tout cas moi le
premier est depuis des années les
comptes
et je crois que face à cette personne
qui témoignée d'une peur que j'ai comme
lui une anxiété qui parfois peut me
bouffer au quotidien
pour la première fois de ma vie j'étais
silencieux
silencieux en fait alors que je devais
moi bah faire rebondir leur donner envie
leur donner envie de participer à ce
débat qui était venu faire mon cerveau a
complètement buggé rien
alors quand je vous dis rien rien
j'ai peut-être oublié un élément dans
cet introduction bonjour
moi je m'appelle Quentin je suis
responsable d'un incubateur de start-up
mais je suis aussi parti d'un programme
un programme qui aide à faciliter la
réinsertion des détenus par comme vous
l'avez deviné l'entrepreneuriat
alors on parlait de quoi anxiété on a
parlé de réchauffement climatique mais
au final ces problèmes je suis désolé de
vous annoncer qui sont pas forcément
seuls et qui forment à peu près un tout
en tout cas une espèce de grande famille
une grande catégorie qu'on va appeler
les problèmes sociétaux
alors pour faire un dessin très rapide
qui n'est pas issu de la recherche qui
de mémo quand j'explique à mes parents
après une société c'est quoi bah c'est
un problème qui peut tous nous toucher
je vous donne un exemple
exemple tristement célèbre
cet été la France a été proie à de
nombreux incendies
il va pas vous demander votre carte
d'identité votre compte en banque et
l'état du contrat d'assurance que vous
avez pour votre maison avant de brûler
votre maison non et ça que vous soyez
quelqu'un dans ce public ou bien Arnaud
même avec des milliards sur votre compte
l'incendie va passer
l'incendie et les feux de forêts c'est
une conséquence qu'on a dû à mon
climatique et on sait aujourd'hui que on
va en avoir de plus en plus et que donc
on va devoir s'adapter
et malheureusement des problèmes
sociétaux il y en a d'autres
égalité des chances égalité des gens
intégration des vagues d'immigration
réinsertion dans la société
et malheureusement il y en a d'autres et
aujourd'hui tous ces problèmes on voit
qui augmentent on voit qu'ils continuent
mais comme on a dit qu'il fallait pas
avoir peur face à innovation et face au
problème bah on va maintenant commencer
à partir où justement on va être un peu
plus dynamique et on va essayer de voir
ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui il y a
des projets qui au quotidien mènent des
combats contre ces problèmes il y a des
projets qui vont donner leur énergie
leurs ressources leur envie leur temps à
ces problèmes
ces projets ils sont pas là pour gagner
de l'argent ils sont rentables vous
inquiétez pas mais ils sont là pour
résoudre des problématiques
ces projets là ils appellent les projets
impacts
ils font généralement partie ce qu'on
appelle l'économie sociale et solidaire
et le but de ces projets là c'est même
de disparaître une fois que c'est
problématiques ont été résolus c'est
pour la plupart dans leur statut il y a
une fin une fin qui est si ce problème
est fini j'ai fini le projet disparaît
alors pour vous donner quelques exemples
et pour revenir aussi un peu en arrière
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi moi
j'interviens en détention
en gros la détention
vous savez quoi on va faire un autre
exercice
je vais pas vous demander de fermer les
yeux vous inquiétez pas mais je vous
demandais d'imaginer ce que c'est 9
mètres carrés
généralement quand on imagine 9 mètres
carrés on va commencer par les murs on
va commencer par la hauteur sous plafond
ok tout le monde à peu près une image
dans ces 9 mètres carrés vous allez
rajouter un lavabo
vous allez rajouter une douche
vous allez rajouter des toilettes
et vous allez rajouter une télé ou une
plaque de cuisson
est-ce que tout le monde a à peu près
une image alors je suis au courant que
c'est plus simple pour des étudiants que
pour des personnes qui sont dans
l'emploi je sais très bien mais est-ce
que tout le monde a à peu près une image
ouais
dans ces 9 mètres carrés je vais vous
demander rajouter
un lit
vous savez les lits qu'on faisait quand
vous avez des cabanes qu'on était enfant
vous savez les livres où il y a pas de
sommier juste un lit par terre comme ça
on en met très bien dedans d'ailleurs il
y a aucun souci là-dessus
est-ce que tout le monde a une image
avoir votre tête je pense que oui même
si je vois pas trop le fond de la salle
ok maintenant je vais vous demander de
rajouter deux autres lits
mais bon pour vous
vous venez d'imaginer les conditions de
détention dans certains centres
pénitenti en France 9 mètres carrés
trois lits trois personnes aucune
intimité
alors il y a d'autres chiffres en soit
des tensions en France
sans cesse pour cent sans cesse pour
cent c'est la surpopation carcérale
française donc en gros les 16% en plus
des 100% bah c'est lui qu'on vient
d'évoquer le liquide par terre
75% 75% c'est simple c'est le nombre de
personnes qui au bout d'un an de sortie
ne trouve pas d'emploi
et enfin 65%, 65% c'est le nombre de
détenus qui au bout de 5 ans sont en
récidives il retourne en prison
aujourd'hui c'est très clair le système
carcéral français un problème de
réinsertion
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à ça
et ben nous on a monté un programme ou
le but pour nous bah c'est d'aller
d'intervenir en détention comme on l'a
fait en terre mais comme on le fait
aussi ça tous
et de donner l'image de ce que peut être
un entrepreneur au quotidien
alors histoire qu'on soit tous d'accord
sur l'image entrepreneur est-ce que vous
voyez qui c'est Jeff Bezos
tout le monde voit qui sait déjà pas
Grand Surprise là dessus le MI patron
d'une boîte qui grosse boîte qui
s'appelle comme une forêt et mi méchant
de James Bond si pour moi quelqu'un qui
envoie les hommes les plus riches de la
terre en espace qui veut coloniser
d'autres planètes et qui fait tout ça
avec un sourire qui fait parfois très
très peur j'appelle ça un méchant de
James Bond
est-ce que tout le monde a l'image de ce
type ouais
ben nous on veut pas du tout ça non nous
on veut donner l'image des entrepreneurs
du quotidien les artisans les TPE les
PME parfois les startupers
mais en fait toutes les personnes que
vous croisez dans votre quotidien
pour une raison très simple en fait
entreprendre on va prendre le verbe on a
tous entrepris quelque chose dans nos
vies vous avez entrepris de faire des
études vous avez entrepris de partir de
chez vous aux entrepris de vous mettre
en couple parfois vous avez entreprises
d'arrêter la clope bon il y en a
certains qui ont arrêté d'entreprendre
je pense mais bon on a tous entrepris
une fois dans nos vies et nous le but et
je pense que vous êtes assez nombreux
dans cette salle même si vous êtes
étudiant c'est de montrer en fait les
réussites et les échecs de cette posture
entrepreneuriale et non pas le métier
d'entrepreneur
du coup nous on intervient des tensions
avec des personnes qui viennent partager
leur peur leur réussite leurs échecs
leur motivation ce qu'ils auraient pu
faire de mieux
et le but pour nous c'est que bah on
explique ce que c'est d'avoir une potion
entrepreneuriale que soit d'un point de
vue professionnel mais aussi que ce soit
pas vue personnel en plus on accompagne
aussi des gens d'un point de vue
individuel parce que faire du groupe
c'est bien mais individuellement c'est
aussi important surtout en détention
et à la sortie une fois que nous
bénéficiaires sortent de détention bah
on va essayer de les connecter avec le
monde qu'ils entoure parce que pour
certains c'est très compliqué de se
reconnecter à la société donc on va leur
donner des contacts d'association
d'établissement public d'entreprises
et pour ceux qui veulent vraiment monter
un projet entrepreneurial on va les
accompagner
alors c'est quoi ma petite tâche à moi
dans tout ça
bah moi au quotidien je suis chargé de
d'innover
grand terme le but pour moi c'est
d'améliorer les process d'aller plus
loin de comprendre de quoi on va avoir
besoin maintenant mais aussi plus tard
de faire en sorte que le petit impact
qu'on peut avoir sur la région
toulousaine comment on fait pour le
maximiser et comment on fait pour aller
sur la France entière
la communication comment je vais faire
pour communiquer faire comprendre aux
gens que il y a un problème en détention
que ils peuvent intervenir eux aussi
comme vous bon la plupart du temps c'est
pas faire des dédics sous la semaine je
vous rassure quand même
comment je vais faire pour Moutier
comment je vais faire pour que tous les
l'équipe qu'on a au quotidien a les
meilleurs outils pour pouvoir faire leur
tâche
vraiment je venais du monde de la
start-up
en me demandait de scaler
alors pour ceux qui sont pas adepte du
terme Skyler grandir vite fort trop fort
mais très très fort dans tous les cas ce
qui me disait qu'on me demandait des
stratégies de gagner de l'argent pas
gagner de l'argent c'est aussi
l'objectif et c'est le seul objectif
qu'on avait à terme combien je vais
gagner d'argent
je vous assure qu'au quotidien innover
pour du bon sens innover pour quelque
chose de positif ça change une vie
vraiment je me retrouvais plus dans mes
anciens métiers et aujourd'hui j'arrive
vraiment à me dire ok j'ai une offre
pour quelque chose j'ai une offre pour
quelque chose qui a de l'impact
et pour quelqu'un comme moi qui a
extrêmement du mal à se lever le matin
bah ça donne une certaine source de
motivation quand même
alors théoriquement à ce moment là de la
TEDx je suis censé vous faire une belle
transition
c'est plus simple vous savez belle
transition pour comprendre mais moi je
préfère juste vous parler d'une citation
entre nous pendant entre nous entre moi
les 100 personnes qui me regardent
j'ai pas retenu grand chose de la philo
au lycée
voilà je pense que je suis pas le seul
non plus
mais il y a une phrase qui bizarrement
j'ai retenu tout de suite et qui
m'accompagne encore aujourd'hui
science sans conscience n'est que ruines
de l'âme mon prof de philo serait ravi
de citer durable et pendant une TX mais
je ne sais pas pourquoi cette phrase est
restée en moi et on va y revenir après
vous inquiétez pas
comme je dis sans transition aucune
qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant qu'on a
des projets impacts
les problèmes je pense qu'on se
rencontre tous ils existent au quotidien
et ils existent même de plus en plus on
a une société qui de plus en plus a des
problèmes visibles et en tout cas ce qui
était invisible avant deviennent de plus
en plus visible
pas des projets impacts il y en a de
plus en plus aussi mais pas assez pour
résoudre tous les problèmes
et même dans ces projets impacts là
comme toute entreprise ou comme tout
projet il y a aussi des réussites et des
échecs
alors comment on fait
eBay on se sert les coudes au quotidien
on essaye d'avancer et croyez moi pour
avoir vécu et vivre encore dans un
projet impact tous les jours concilier
innovation
impact mais aussi réussite économique
parce qu'on doit être rentable bah ça se
fait ça se donne en tout cas énormément
de mal de crâne
ou pour d'autres personnes ça leur
permet de s'arracher les derniers
cheveux qu'ils ont sur la tête moi j'ai
eu la chance il y en avait déjà pas
avant moi c'était plus rapide
du coup on fait quoi face à ce projet
impact face à toutes ces problématiques
et ben je suis venu ici pour justement
pas de musiquement par les deux mois
mais pour donner aussi l'envie de alors
l'envie de quoi
bah si toi au quotidien et je m'adresse
bien à toi même si tu mon regard se pose
pas sur toi je m'adresse à toi si tu
peux pas être dans un projet impact
sache que tu peux faire plein de choses
tu peux relayer leur communication tu
peux t'intéresser tu peux être curieux
tu peux essayer de devenir leurs clients
tu peux essayer de devenir leur
financeur tu peux essayer de voir
comment au quotidien tu peux impacter
c'est hyper important et on va en avoir
vraiment besoin parce que aujourd'hui on
a une réelle motivation et une réelle
besoin de tout transformer de se rendre
compte que les problèmes ils sont là au
quotidien et d'arrêter de passer à côté
de se rendre compte que objectiver la
réussite économique d'un projet ça
suffit plus de se rendre compte que
innover c'est bien mais innover pour
exclure ou innover pour créer des effets
de rebond ça ne marche pas à ce titre là
ne me demandez pas mon avis sur les NFC
le metaves ou le prix du dernier iPhone
surtout le prix du dernier iPhone
et surtout il faut que vous vous rendiez
compte que au quotidien vous avez un
impact même si vous faites pas un projet
impact
pour reprendre la petite phrase de
Rabelais
je vais vous donner ma vision moderne
aujourd'hui pour moi
innover pour résoudre des problèmes
c'est impératif si aujourd'hui
l'innovation ne résout pas de problème
mais en crée d'autres sera pas notre
ruine de lame non ce sera la rune de
tout le monde et de notre société
les plans ils ont été donnés les
discours ils ont été prononcés les
problèmes ils existent les solutions
elles existent aussi il ne reste qu'une
seule chose l'action à vous de jouer
merci